what I'm going to talk about today is
what has happened as we've moved through
the intelligent interface world and
where we need to move from here we've
been working on direct manipulation as a
way of making more recognizably simple
interfaces for decades and the real
issue that's changed is that whereas
making an efficient interface was a
great idea ten years ago today the most
important problem isn't isn't whether
it's efficient but whether it's
effective whether we are going to be
motivated to use it because at any
moment we are either in a veil of a
social circumstance or we can jump to
another place on the computer and do a
million things and ari regardless of
what our boss tells us to do and as well
as the graphical user interface issues
of being more better being effect
efficient effective we have to think
about the the goal itself of efficiency
as we think about efficiency we have to
really think about the fact that the
stickiness is more interesting than then
even the ping the slipperiness and so as
we've been trying to make computers more
useful more part of our lives we've
really found ourselves trying to
understand recognise the situation and
work within the context of that
situation I ran a group called
context-aware computing for a decade
when people weren't so sure that they
could actually recognize context now we
think we can but the problem is when we
use reasoning systems and learning
systems to understand the communication
powder that's going on between a person
and a computer or the goals and tasks
that a person they're doing we are still
in a situation where the person has to
decide that that's what they want to be
doing and what I started discover
along this route was that in in in my
systems my context-aware systems
actually what was more important than
anything was if the system didn't
distract disrupt disorganize a person
and if a person wanted to use it and so
just a simple thing we had a user
interface that would comment on the kind
of text you're using not about swearing
but you know the anger and surprise and
frustration in your emails and when it
put up a some words saying you know
surprised angry what I you know upset
people didn't pay attention when we put
up a face that showed those emotions
people change the writing okay when we
made a car that would tell you every
time you forgot to blink the press loved
it but when we made that car tell all of
the problems you were driving and all of
the positive things you were driving you
drove horse when we had it only tell you
the positive things brewed driving
smoothly good breaking smooth steering
people drove horse and when we said
negative things only they drove horse
when did they drive better with the
system when we used a variable schedule
of reinforcement and we're very careful
to make sure that there was a lot of
positive feedback but that we didn't
talk to people when they were
cognitively loaded how do you how do you
know that well you know if they're doing
three things at once that's a good time
not to say something if you have two or
three things to say it once maybe that's
a good place to do it so now I'm really
faced with the interesting thing that
may be more exciting to me for a while
for now is a layer that would be about
when to communicate and why to
communicate to keep from disrupting and
to keep people engaged and so this this
layer that I have been working on I call
considerate systems and on just as an
example we made a system a few years ago
called disruption manager just published
at interact less summer in which we were
able to get thirty percent performance
improvement for people taking orders
while they were taking im's emails and
and playing with their their their web
and some stuff like this this is kind of
amazing taking into account the topic
you know low level things like what
they're typing and mouse movements and
high-level things by like the relevance
between things we were able to disagree
organize the actions a little bit so as
we as we're trying to understand if we
really are going to be effective at
making that social layer the feedback
the social feedback should you be
speaking now what is going on the you
you can choose between a variety of
domains if you think about communicating
in a feed-forward way that's that's this
considerate person we call the hostess
every time somebody comes into the
restaurant or the party that person says
welcome good to see you you look great
you look marvelous and and no matter
what they say or whatever what happens
they make them keep the people feel
welcomed now it would be feedback if one
of them looks kind of pale and and the
person says I'm do you need to sit down
that isn't as off as common actually
right we run into that's that's that
social feedback with that's considered
feedback with feedback all of the
scenarios we're going to work on today
have feedback we are going to take into
account the signal from the person
that's working as part of it but we're
going to start off in a difficult
scenario purposely to demonstrate that
it is that it is a generalized
domain-independent approach to q2 to
adding this layer of considerateness
that we're able to get we start off with
audio between people not between a
computer and a system so now there is no
way unless we were doing a lot of speech
reco and and summarization and then and
there and stuff which which of course is
coming along but not great um 22 to
facilitate what we are instead doing is
listening to two other other issues
about the phone call and deciding how
help with the phone call why audio audio
is exciting domain for for a lot of
reasons one is it's a broadcast medium
it's kind of a mess that way and in fact
if you have a conference call it's an
overloaded channel there everybody could
talk at once and they still with you no
they you know anyway it and and you know
you would get nowhere so how do we make
a conference call better and with it
with that I'm going to turn it over to
Rowell who's going to tell you about the
Cameo system that does consider it audio
mediation to to improve conference calls
and other audio kinds of communication
thanks Ted I want to begin my part of
the talk with the code from Martha
where she says we want to build
in thousand actors not just intelligent
thinkers and I want to use this to frame
the rest of the talk because there's
normally three parts to building an AI
system there is a sensing there's a
reasoning and there's the action but not
a lot of focus on the action so in this
talk I want to I want to frame frame the
rest of the talk with this with this
focus so I'm going to start with talking
about intelligent actors and how they're
becoming a reality in our lives because
we no longer use these just to crunch
numbers but they encroaching in all our
social spaces from smart cars mediated
communications and personal agents like
Siri now Clifford Nass here at Stanford
has shown that we treat these
intelligent actors as social actors we
expect them to adhere to the same social
rules that we hold each other to and
indeed there's been commercial examples
of this Clippy which is one of the first
intelligent systems to be commercially
available was not very popular but
theory on the other hand is relatively
more popular because it fails more
gracefully and so this this notion of
social actors and social interfaces is
not new and there's been a lot of
research especially in these two areas
social signal processing and affective
computing is microphone on social signal
brought soup in this picture you have a
couple and and looks like they're in the
middle of a fight right and there's a
lot of social signals just from that
picture the gays the distance between
them and processing that social signal
and recognizing this is called social
signal processing and being able to
respond to that is is what we call
effect is not on yeah it's working cool
responding to this so as to simulate
empathy is what what affective computing
is and and and this is very social very
at the very surface level we can see
using emoticons mobile phones that
change the display based on the mood
conversational agents and you may even
have personal robots now so the next
step is to build socially intelligent
systems not just at the surface level
but they're able to make social
decisions based on more sophisticated
reasoning so if I were to enter a room
where a couple is in the middle of a
fight you know I would modulate my
actions right I might not interrupt them
leave the room do various things and
that that's what i mean by the social
reasoning right okay so basically this
sides telling us that social reasoning
and social intelligence is pretty pretty
complicated and what we want to do as a
first step in building considered
systems it's just focus on the action
part right so assuming certain things on
the sensing and make making a number of
simplifications but i'm focusing on the
action part and in particular and
focusing on two actions advisory and
assistive so here's a formal definition
for considered systems systems that
display an awareness of the state of the
user and the situated social context by
behaving in ways that support human
human and human machine interactions
that is behaving appropriately and
that's really the soul of what we mean
by considered systems now scientific
definition there's a lot of parts to it
it's our whole big agenda
but in this talk I'm going to focus on
this particular point parameterizing of
the actions right so I want to support
interactions by providing some feedback
and the question is how am I going to
parameterize this action so we built an
example our system that we call cameo we
choose the teleconference domain because
a number of reasons first it's very
popular but it has pretty low
satisfactory ratings you can see your
compared to face to face meeting web
conferences etc also it's a very well
studied domain so the problems are very
well defined like in this compilation by
Yankovic who surveyed participants after
a number of meetings he basically
grouped the problems into three
categories behavioral audio and
technical and we're going to focus on on
four of these problems because they
represent a large percentage but what's
interesting here is that Yankovic says
that you see how the audio problems are
have a lot of complaints and they're
technical but he says these problems are
actually social because of the of the
social pressure people have against you
know breaking the conversation and
pointing out a problem so if one of you
were to interrupt me and say hey I can't
hear it's an interruption and there's a
social pressure against doing that so
this brings us to our problem statement
can we use a considerate agent to
improve distributed communications using
advisory and assistive action so I'll
get into what i mean by advisory in
assistive actions but let me first give
you a cybernetics perspective this is a
normal conference call you have the
conference call you have the
participants talking and we want to add
an agent which we call cameo considered
audio mediating Oracle and we give cameo
to actions assistive and advisory
assistive when it's directly influencing
the channel so it's muting somebody
putting reverb on the channel that's
assistive it's directly influencing the
channel advisory is when it's
doing something to the Parsons hey maybe
you can do this better all right it's
giving some advice of the parchment
hoping that the participants effect some
change in the conference call so before
I jump into cameo I'm going to briefly
go over some of the related work and how
people have tackled this problem one
very popular interface is the loops
Babel interface from IBM and basically
they came up with this social
translucent framework and what they're
saying is that if you increase
visibility you give rise to awareness
which in turn gives rise to
accountability and they explain it with
this story which I'll I'll narrate
imagine you have a door that opens from
a hallway into a stairway now if you
open the door fast likely to hit into
someone trying to come in the other way
and you can can imagine trying to solve
this problem by putting a sign on the
door that says please open carefully
where it doesn't work that well as you
probably experienced a better solution
would be to put a glass store glass
window in the door and now you have
you're creating this visibility and thus
awareness and thus accountability and
that's what their story is another group
at MIT built a meeting mediator which is
basically you have this device that
participants wear and that's measuring
you know how much you're talking etc and
everyone gets to see a visualization so
you have say for participants and each
of them has a mobile phone which with
this visualization on the phone the four
corners indicate the four participants
in the meeting this the the circle
indicates the balance in the meeting
right and the color indicates the level
of interactivity so in this window on
the left you have a very balanced
meeting right people are talking equally
participating on the right you have
participant why who's dominating the
meeting and what they showed is that
providing this kind of feedback can
change behavior now what we are
wondering is if we can provide proactive
actions because these has been shown to
be even more successful at getting users
to change the behavior and let me
compare those related works
a common social problem of spilling so
we can compare the social translucence
to our political and not probably police
and judicial system right and that that
gives rise to accountability the passive
feedback is like the speedometer where
you know how fast you're going and this
new modulate your actions and the
proactive actions which have been shown
to be most successful is SD is this P is
the radar gun flashing your speed that's
okay and these are this has been shown
be more successful in getting people to
slow down so the question is can we use
this inside when building cameo okay so
I'm going to focus on five features
which are drawn from their problems that
I brought up before the first to
dominance dormancy extraneous noise i'm
going to try to tackle with advisor your
actions the last three speaker
identification arts minh presents
entry/exit notification i'm going to try
and tackle with assistive actions a
quick look at the architecture basically
i have participants collaborating
remotely each participant gets their own
blackboard architecture which is this
conflict resolution mechanism right so
each parchment gets a channel Iser which
is monitoring them t keeping track of
you know whether they're speaking or not
how loudly this speaking was the
background noise on their channel and
similarly there's a blackboard for the
whole meeting the global Iser that's
keeping track of all the participants
has someone entered or left the meeting
is someone being dominant and basically
very things get populated into the
priority queue and finally get pushed
into the text-to-speech module which is
the main actuator for cameo so we built
this system and we started playing with
it became immediately apparent that it's
very difficult to introduce actions in
two and two are already overloaded
communication channel says imagine your
five people talking and then you have
this agent trying to say something it's
very difficult to get it right and it's
very easy to disrupt the communication
to get participants annoyed and so one
of the
no the big takeaways from me and
something I want to share here is that
any action has two components to it you
are communicating information but you're
also negotiating a relationship type so
it's back to that old adage it's not
it's not what you say it's how you say
right so am I trying to dominate you am
I trying to command you am I trying to
be friendly right and other things we
want to keep in mind is that we want to
be perceived by the user as pertinent
and thoughtful and not distracting
condescending or hostile okay so the
first problem that we want to attack her
from this list is the the meeting was
not well facilitated people talking too
much too little it was shown to be the
numbers on the right let me explain that
six percent is the number of people who
is surveyed who found that to be a
problem and a p-value of 0 point 0 0
indicates that this problem was highly
impacted meeting effectiveness so quite
a significant problem now the question
is how do we design these these prompts
these actions right we have you want to
make an advisory reaction and the
question is how do we how do we design
it and so do we make I just want to
contrast to two types of actions for you
there's a long right it's long it's
commanding imagine hearing that a couple
of times when you're talking to other
people as compared to say that again
short suggestive right similarly for
doorman
all right as opposed to so now now
you're wondering ok so do be able to get
anything with this action and so I'm
going to talk about the experiment we
designed what we found out was that our
research has shown that particular types
of meeting especially brainstorming
meetings work better when everyone's
talking more equally right so you have
constructive and if you can get
constructive interaction styles you get
better performance on the flip side when
there's varying dominance when someone's
talking loud so I was not talking enough
you get passive in in passive and
defensive interaction styles which is
what we don't want and then our
hypothesis is that using advisory
reactions we can decrease this this
variance and dominance so what we did
was we got 12 groups of three
participants we had them collaborating
remotely on hangman puzzles and
basically they had to follow a protocol
where everyone agrees on on a letter and
the last person to agree on the letter
puts letter in and so we have right
different rooms the only video this is
this the the hangman screen and just
collaborating we had this be had in grew
in in intra-group study so the same
people doing this doing the doing the
experiment with cameo and without cameo
and what we found was that without cameo
there is a large variance in in dominant
suit without camera is this red line
this is the dominance levels of the
different participants dominance levels
that's that's the participants just
plotting the Dominus levels of the
participants and you can see that
without cameo mediating there's a large
variance in in in in the participation
levels what happens if someone starts
talking and the other people is that n
keep going and the doorman people remain
dormant contrast this with the blue
curve where you have people
where you can see the variance is a
large car we're talking almost almost
half the variance and that's a very
powerful statement to make with just the
two our trenches that I made you here
previously so we can conclude that
cameos advisory reactions reduced
variants in the dominance levels and
what's even more surprising here is that
people said that they didn't they didn't
notice the prompts it's kind of scary
because that means that nothing would
show up in the data but the data was a
different quite surprising okay so the
next problem we wanted to focus when was
too much extraneous noise again a
problem that twenty percent of the
people felt very significantly attacked
impacted meeting effectiveness ok so
again how do you design this there's a
pressure to not disrupt the meeting I
this is social pressure people feel I
don't want it I don't want to disrupt
the meeting and say hey can you turn
that volume down right and this is where
we felt cameo could take the role of the
bad guy cameo can be more persistent
especially it's it's a private
notification only only the offending
party gets to hear it so the
communication goes on as normal only you
hear it in your channel and and we have
let me just make you hear it it's a very
short and sort notification that's all I
just noisy right so how do you evaluate
this how do you evaluate this um we
wanted to simulate a problem solving
session at high cognitive load what we
had the participants do is tackle a
chess problem a mate in three chess
puzzle and same scenario the sitting in
different rooms collaborating on the mic
but much more involved and deep
discussion right because you have to
drink three levels into the problem and
so in the rooms of one of the part
smells like that said we had a TV and we
would incrementally increase the volume
of the TV and we would give the the
participant has a remote control and we
said see if anyone on the line or if
cameo prompts you then
reduce the volume right so and what and
what we found was that again the same
thing at the same group with cameo
mediating and without cameo mediating
and we were when we found that is that
when the TV volume increased someone on
the line would say hey that's loud can
you turn that down all right but the
person would do it then a couple of
minutes into the meeting we would turn
the volume back up again but this time
no one said anything instead what they
did was they just started talking louder
and what happened as this started
talking now you could feel it you could
feel it in the room the the temperature
of the room increased they started
getting more aggressive about about the
position because you know they're all
arguing about which which moved to make
and this was reflected in the data with
with cameo are mediating there are only
seven interrupts in a for meeting for
minute meeting as opposed to twelve and
a half without cameo mediating by
interrupts interrupts I mean I'm talking
and somebody else talks over me and cuts
me off so that's an impasse where we
count as an interrupt and you can see
just with that just with that
notification noisy we're able to cut
down the number of interrupts by half
and and you know as witnessing all this
you can see that the interaction was the
same people the same time frame which is
doing cameo mediating and then they
continue with cameo not mediating and
this was balanced half the time cameo
started and the other half cameo started
in the second part so again concluding
that camis advisory action was able to
reduce the impact the third problem was
that it's difficult to identify who's
speaking okay so I'm just going to play
a quick sample of
what is it right so this is this is five
people trying to talk together to make a
decision and you're trying to identify
who's speaking they're all non-native
English speakers yeah it can become very
hard to tell who's speaking and so to
tackle this problem we thought of
introducing your cons that is when I
start speaking a music track starts
playing so that's more easier to
identify me initially we started with
the instrumental track so I'm based in
someone else's drums and it becomes very
hard to focus on the conversation
because this is a lot of crosstalk so
instead of that instead of playing
tracks full tracks we thought we might
use tonal pulses so just these tones
that are pulsing every time you make an
utterance we started off with using the
same timber but barring the pitch
different notes of a card but again it
becomes very difficult to distinguish
between the different notes what we
ended up doing was using different
timbres I'll make you hear that so the
different timbres are tambourine muted
electric bass bongo and a vibraphone
as you can see as you hear the different
tones it becomes much easier to
distinguish between yes did you find a
limit on the number of these that could
be workable uh that comes up in a
noxious experiment where we kind of
identified 12 and many people not
getting to say anything and you'll see
that in a few minutes okay so we also
added spatial cues we said okay no
accuses the baseline spatial cues is the
gold standard right if I place the
speakers on in different on different
degrees on the stereo panning that's
going to be the gold standard so we
compared all three in an experiment so
we had we had people listen to this
conference call five people
collaborating we added these cues these
assistive audio cues because our
hypothesis is that these articles can
help participants and distinguish
between speakers much easier we had 32
participants listening to this and
answering questions related to who
suggested that chocolate was a good idea
all right so answering questions of that
nature and what we found was that with
the year cons and the spatial facial the
Yukons and spatial pretty much dirty
clear well they did much better than
having no audio cues right this is
accuracy the the ear cons are those
little timber sounds you said they are
going to see better accuracy and reduced
response time in both the spatial and in
these little little little added noises
right and comparable to the gold
standard which we said is placing the
speakers spatially so we
able to show that cameos this particular
assistive action to identify speakers by
adding audio cues on the channel help
others to distinguish between the
speakers finally there's a this problem
not able to tell who was in the meeting
who joined who left and we have two
experiments that I will talk about the
first part not tell who was in the
meeting participant presence now
our initial idea was to build a
soundscape so you know there's five
people in the room there's going to be
fire instruments and you hear the
soundscape in the background so you know
that people are there even though
they're not talking and if and if you
hear a particular instrument drop off
then you realize that someone dropped
off the line all right and again we
tried the instrumental instrumental
first what you're hearing the bongos
shakers and strings and as you can jerk
it's a very strong presence on the audio
line can be a little distracting so we
try to tone it down a bit by using
nature sounds instead put your hearing a
bird see crickets sound of ocean water
but it still has a bit of a load o it
happens right it's and it's it's it's a
pretty clearly it gets interesting
because it's difficult to pretty a
notice when something is dropped off so
we decided to try the roll call method
where okay so you're having this
conference call someone hasn't talked in
a while so we make keyboard noises or
are you know opening and closing the
drawer just to show that these guys
still present he's on the line is just
he hasn't talked in a while right and
what we found was it's hard to it gets
hard to map these sounds to particular
users so we were using dynamic mapping
so every time someone became quite we
would dynamically assigned instruments
oh yeah oh yeah so what you'll hear is
the sound of keyboard
the sound of a drawer opening and
closing boss alright okay so you're
probably wondering the same thing I was
when I designed this and I like is it
really going to help right and so we
designed an experiment same thing again
people are listening to this conference
call we add these cues and and what we
told them was look this these guys were
in a in a in a low signal quality area
and there's a high likelihood that some
of them drop off because they're moving
here and there and it's your job to make
sure that everyone's online it's soap
yeah we give them a nudge burden which
gives them feedback that everyone's
present and it was their job to
periodically nudge to make sure that
everyone is on line and we're wondering
what's the difference in these two
scenarios we had between group study
where some people listen to the
conference call with cues and some
people listen to it without the cues and
it surprised to find that with the Q's
people made 3.5 nudges on average and
without the cues they were nudging a lot
more and this isn't a 4-minute
conference call so it did make a
difference and right to
they notice ah so again it's you talk to
the participants after the after the
experiment and it's it's it's it's it's
uncanny they don't they don't notice at
their own theory as did you hear the
keyboard sounds no I don't think I did
which is which is which is the
surprising part because we are getting
results that's saying that you know some
sort of impact is happening might be
happening it subconsciously I don't know
but something is happening and we were
able to see it although the participles
themselves don't notice it which is a
good thing because you don't want to be
intruding on the conference call and
that's the whole point here to be
considerate ok so finally we wanted to
use explore different types of entry and
exit mechanisms because you know current
systems they use they have this big
speech prompt which is annoying if you
hear if sitting and you know people
coming in and going out it gets annoying
because it starts talking and then
suddenly you get this prompt so we're
wondering what are the other kinds of
things we can do to announce entry and
exit we started with iconic prongs which
is the sound of a door using the sound
of a door to indicate and feel exit so
here's entrance you're opening and the
name exit John the name and the door
closing we did this different sequencing
because parchment said that it was hard
to differentiate between door opening
and door closing see if I've so yeah
nothing like say 30 in the conference
calls yes there's a 37 in that in that
dominance won earlier the evaluations
have a lot people evaluating it but the
conference calls themselves are small
smaller conference call these are all
results that were stating we found
result we have statistical significance
of that at the ninety-five percent no
I'm more a matter of just trying to
distinguish voices yeah I mean when you
have 30 people at so much harder yes
well but 30 people are not going to be
speaking at the same time no no he's in
conference
tell us where there's a hundred people
yeah I had it I had a 30-person one
earlier today okay and in fact you're
going to be raising some questions there
was another staffer funder technicolor
research live had a discussion today it
was a audio bases will too but they're
more questions on privacy how you guys
didn't address that and I'll save that
for the year ok I will find to make
about lodge it might be interesting to
use these cues to indicate role are you
a designer or engineer are you
affiliated with Stanford of its CNU I
mean just giving some sort of background
about the speaker might also be useful
if you can't give the full identity with
that would be beyond will be done to
this moment right and finally we also
tried metaphoric prov are using fade and
intonation so let's quickly play that
John so that's entry with the normal
intonation and for exit we use John
power for detonation so again we're
wondering if doing these design does
anything doesn't matter there's anything
come out of it and so we designed an
experiment where we had people randomly
dropped off the call and collaborating
and basically they were collaborating on
a on a memory game so cards would pop up
on the screen in their selected card
would turn face over and they would have
to remember it to select a similar car
card the next time they turn came and so
what we were doing was we had a group
the four participants each group went
through three of the prompts each group
experienced it if the Pawn prompts and
what we found was that so we actually
had a protocol let me quickly tell you
about that so this is so there's four
people are collaborating in two teams
right so me and my partner another team
with two partners and the way it works
is I pick a card and my partner doesn't
see which card I picked I have to
explain the car to them and then they
pick their card all in distributed
collaboration now the protocol was that
my partner and I alternate who picks the
first card so if this turn I picked the
first card the next turn my partner fix
the fix the first card and when we found
was that with the metaphoric prompt
which is this is the intonation using
just the upward and downward inclination
people made a lot fewer errors in in
that protocol as compared to the iconic
and the speech people are making lock
mirrors again with the statistical
significance and that's interesting so
what's interesting is that initially
people were preferred the speech prompt
to the metaphoric prompts and the iconic
prompts but after they got familiar with
the metaphoric once they understood the
metaphor they prefer that because it's a
shorter and to the point but what's more
interesting is that it actually
impacting the cognitive ability of the
of the of the participants here in that
they're making fewer errors in this case
errors in the following the protocol
okay so I ran through fire experiments
the first to be sure we can attack using
the advisory actions and this last three
we we tackle using the assistive actions
to conclude intelligent actors are
social actors and they need to have some
semblance of social intelligence
intelligence requires you to be able to
sense reason and act in this talk we're
focusing in action and in particular
considered systems is focusing on
supporting interactions using advisory
and assistive actions we built an
exemplar system which we call cameo I'm
a demonstrated that we can advise
reactions work best with nadja like
phrases and assistive actions have to be
synchronous with the interaction
so just to bring up a discussion we were
talking about how an agent makes actions
right so if you have advisory in a
system what it really comes out of it is
that there's a syntax and semantics for
this considerate feedback language and
the next question is when do you make
these actions do so we could pull from
cognitive psychology where they have
different forms of reinforcement
feedback and think about you know when
an agent makes an action so someone's
being dominant you can have different
levels of of actions one as you just
advise them and other one is you the
most extreme it could be you just mute
them all right so when do you choose
which action and at what scale and
degree and and and finally just to
connect the dots we were looking at
action but then we also need to
integrate with in other communities
doing sensing social signal processing
and the reasoning and with that I'll
hand it over to Ted so you can see we
we've had surprising success I mean the
reason i call it surprising actually is
because we found dozens of ways of
making these conference calls much worse
almost everything we did adding sound
made them worse and it took us a couple
years actually before we ended up having
these these these things that look so
simple today on the papers that
represent this are at chi 2012 there's
one and also there's another paper at
design interaction and systems designing
interactive system designing interactive
systems last summer it's a great
conference by the way and then there's
another one we've submitted to chi for
this year of interact 2013 so those are
those are places where you can find out
more about it to just look online really
the most important thing to realize is
you know we've we've only gotten started
we've been taking a look just at the
human human communication human you know
computer interactions changing now it's
going to be human system interaction of
course the system cannot people and and
computers and telephones and everything
else and as we move forward you know
what what are we going to take from this
we're building chihiro asuka's working
with us on new new PhD student this week
by the way we're working on the
supervisor level you saw a little bit of
that architecture in which we're going
to make these domain-independent systems
that are going to be all about
understanding when and how to respond
socially and we're going to be trying
them in meeting support in computer
computer operating system support we're
going to be trying on the telephone
support we've been working as you know
in in the past and in cars and kitchens
as you can see from other talks I've
given here and we'd be delighted to work
in that kind of domains as well but
today some of our funding even comes
from people that are interested in how
how to make televisions more socially
appropriate so I just really thank you
guys all for coming here and we're
excited to be hopefully introducing
people to to the thought that social
feedback is going to be crucial as a
field of research and as a technology
that can actually be layered on top of
or integrated into the intelligent user
interfaces that we build in the future
thank you very much you may want to ask
them crush yes either of us when when
okay so this is telecom audio this is
the main channel then we've been using
these fantastic job but the usual reason
people are using audio without visual is
to conserve bandwidth if you follow
putting a display in there so you can
you can use visual we unifications we
you know when the first thing that
happened when Rowell's started getting
on this project is well can't we put in
a display county is it not to begin with
because the real the real you know of
course multimodal interactions are great
and interest
but the question is whether we can
succeed with a very small bandwidth and
not and not changing the modality of the
communication so in fact it was an extra
constriction that we put on ourselves a
constraint i guess to make a more
interesting problem and to be to be
better at knowing whether or not thing
was being useful to you and yeah i have
another comment i don't know if it's
true that we use audio only to conserve
bandwidth because there was a recent
paper that showed that especially in
business meetings audio is still the
most prevalent people prefer video for
home and personal especially because you
become very self-conscious when there's
a camera on you so that that's not
necessarily true that people are using
video or audio only for bandwidth
constraints yeah oh um for all this is
this is cool stuff a couple different
reactions one was the other restriction
you put on yourselves was that the agent
was acting on its own without any
assistance from say the moderator and
you can easily imagine considerably
better effectiveness if the moderator is
somehow part of controlling behavior
another one is varying a sort of what
model you are applying there are some
meetings it's very sensitive I need to
know who's joining as soon as they join
because we want to make sure they're
okay others it's completely open we
actually don't want anyone to interrupt
us we want to just do the discussion and
variations like that so if you take a
look at you know there's dissemination
meetings every one in my kingdom must
obey there there are there are you know
meetings for bringing the team together
we you know we're celebrating Raul
getting his PhD hopes that there there
are meetings where we're brainstorming
and there's meetings were there problems
of those are at least four of the kinds
of meetings that happen and one could
imagine by bringing the right model in
you could make big improvements
one other thing I'm sure you know it
didn't say it quite this way when you
talked about longer versus shorter
advice statements that you gave you also
completely altered the the judgment
quality the first was critical and and
almost passive the second one just
invoked a behavior issue right well i
think i did try to mention it one is
more commanding and the other is more
suggestive and in in every action that
you make you have to realize that you're
negotiating a social relationship there
right that that's that's I think exactly
what your way your break down and so
that's a you know those are all really
important things another thing to point
out about that one of the one of the
funniest things we went to satin with
Terry Winograd and and cliff Nass and
told them about this work and oh this is
this is so exciting why do you make a
company that says well right now it's so
exciting why don't we make a PhD but I'm
really you know that there are different
things you sort of mentioning some if
you were to try to make this be part of
a scenario that would be about making
money sure you could bring in all sorts
of things right now we're just trying to
understand the value of these of the
social bill you understand and react
socially you've been trying to raise
your hand phone yeah um does the system
apni memory from meeting to meeting
because it's the same people show up
then you have the same behaviors and you
can start retraining certain people
earlier and so and you and you know what
they respond to that's the other thing
you get the fabulous idea on you know at
this point 22 Terrell's chagrin we've
spent our time understanding this very
very surface level not reaction I mean
he started off taking you a machine
learning and and and classification a
lot you know closes like that and then
we find ourselves backing backing
backing off to just getting responses
that that serve our purposes they're
moving depths are very exciting when you
start
those things you're talking well you
know you're moving to a different part
of the brain the hard part is the the
chest is the easy problem people are the
hard dealing with people is much harder
so so if you take a look at some of the
other work where we have models
cognitive model of when and why to react
those you know so far individual
differences have not been part of the
agenda it's an interesting area in
general you know universal design is
gets whatever it is ninety percent ten
percent is that is there is the
individual rivers depends on the whole
thing in terms of the model of what what
what the meeting is about and so on but
yes well they're exactly fact that
meetings have a relatively small range
of paradigms that they tend to fit
within it gives you a transactional
repertoire that most of the time people
are familiar with and they might forget
but they're familiar with it and that
gives you an awful lot of leverage yeah
I think I think that's an exciting point
so how much difference is there and sort
of opinions from individual individual
right about how it works yeah I don't
have an audio example but but in terms
of web pages I get really pissed off at
blinky bouncy crap and you know people
that maybe it's just because i'm an old
fart and haven't learned how to you know
play games in crowd right I join up to
be fair I think there is I mean it's
like you said it's I think it's how much
you've been exposed to it so the long
prom the first time I show someone I
show that slightest and when I make them
hear both sides like which one do you
prefer then I don't really care what if
you were in a meeting that where that
prompt kept coming at every five minutes
you kept hearing that it wouldn't I
really annoy you and I think so getting
that kind of opinions would be I think
would really matter if you could get it
into long meetings where you keep
hearing this sort of thing I have been a
stronger reaction to this a lot of the
excitement for me
is in that hangman example where you're
filling out a word you know one word
long and it's no 34 minute task we had
these huge changes in performance when
they had this this feedback I we I think
the these results are quite solid I the
the the you know he says it seems subtle
to people when they're actually trying
to succeed something the distraction
level wheatley when we first started
with that one where we out of the
orchestra and you know we started having
a whole when there's five people there's
a whole you know five piece band playing
oh my gosh the people that we had
helping us do the program we had some
students summer students they just
started quitting they found other jobs
it was so frustrating and annoying you
couldn't believe it and I mean it I i
would say it took us almost a year
before we started finding fighting
results that really were anything but
just really frustrating and yeah there's
easy ways to go to any bag and I see
there's a few students here is there any
student that wants to ask the question
or say something I mean it seems i could
imagine that i'd be a time in the life
that you'll be really curious me yeah
you've wasted on the young yes oh yeah
you don't appreciate it until you get
old then is that either when well as i'm
done as a non-student there's one guy
associated with 38 didn't show up they
Steve Zenith I had a 16 hour drive up
with him to fall to go to Seattle to a
conference and it we were discussing
about artificial intelligence that we're
talking in fact about considering
computing now one of the things that you
pointed out there's about two decades
ago he programmed automatic teller
machines for banks and one things that
really irks them about interactions and
messages is computers don't say please
you really don't like is that only be
leave artificial intelligence steven and
you would say yes as a matter of fact it
is now it kind of you at some point in
time we should probably as when i say we
i mean to 380 infrastructure should
introduce
she to him fantastical to to get to get
some ideas so when you use firefox which
I'm told is something our Akron ism to
some um and you and and and the and the
web browser breaks for one reason or
another it'll come back with oh that oh
this is embarrassing should i restart
all of your things and that is what we
call feed-forward considerate behavior
in other words it doesn't know what I'm
thinking what I'm saying it just knows
its situation and yet just as you're
saying that word please helped it's
tremendously I'm shocked every time it
happens I'm kind of delighted and it
surprises me that it delights me um just
adding that little phrase oh my reaction
is so much more different than that in
fact I think it crashes more than ie and
that's objectively not true it pisses me
off yeah because instead instead of the
instead being polite fix your damn
browser first it's okay second Donna I
can get you the cute weird spin I got I
got stuff that long time ago where the
editor that we were using in the
environment people would use it then go
into programming it's a very long time
ago and the original programmer have the
text say once more dear friends into the
breach and I took over the editor from
the original author and within minutes
of people hearing I taken it over they
were lining up at my door saying please
take that text steph cry so it's not the
problem within Microsoft paperclip know
there's there's a whole bunch of
problems one of the problems with the
paper clip is that it does it makes
visual noise in your periphery or
periphery has a very autonomic tendency
to drag the eye over there because it's
the tiger that's coming after you it's
it's a distance it's down on in your
hippocampus the second thing about it is
that it is taking your attention away
from what you are doing to something
else the third problem that it has is
that um it is about what it's not a how
so if you look at it in his history
berkeley and typically tells you this
this is a text editor or something like
that it doesn't it doesn't solve your
problem and so not being specific enough
and I can probably add more but anyway
they made they made a few little
mistakes they're very I mean what's
funny is there was some serious
cognitive scientists involved and they
made very simple cognitive psychology
mistakes and and and you know his
mistake was that they shipped it yeah
well you know Gotye got ya III don't
want to say too much we found turn it
off by the way it you guys don't realize
it but os/2 at that same time we're
shipping an intelligent help system that
decided how much and what helped to give
you in what site I'm and I designed it
and it was really fabulous with Louis to
of course was you know having this
terrible problem of not having any apps
on it it's a whole world um I don't know
we're just battling this probably enough
for now
you